bonjour là-bas, je suis désolé, alors qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce bang sur la banquette arrière Oh dong c'est
drôle c'est une sculpture que j'ai faite
à l'école
allez à quoi tu penses
conduire avec un bang sur la banquette arrière de
ta voiture qu'est-ce que tu penses que tu  est-ce que
Willie Nelson même s'il a été arrêté
vraiment le temps est une façon terrible de manger
par ma mère m'a écrit ça dans une lettre
quand j'avais huit ans d'accord j'ai eu une décharge
il ne reste que deux semaines avec vous les
gars qu'est-ce qu'on va  faire l'année prochaine, je
pense que je vais faire comme des
drogues hivernales cool comme l'
opium, écoutez-vous bien mon petit
directeur de croisière quand vous savez juste que
vous ne serez pas un athlète professionnel
tu es venu
pourquoi toi et moi allons à Columbia nous
allons être comme des hamburgers pour toujours Je ne
sais même pas si c'est à 100% pourquoi je veux faire
ce dont j'ai besoin mes mecs valent Lily
Je souhaite que Khloe soit là pour manquer notre jeton
amis blancs âne Bona ils sont avec
nous à travers le lycée li  fe Death SATs
prom alors ça va être nous tu es mon
partenaire de vie comme quand tu sais que les choses se
terminent tu flippes et tu essaies de
tenir bon pourquoi es-tu devenu si sage entouré
de femmes brillantes n'es-tu pas
censé être dans mon  classe en ce moment n'êtes-vous pas
censé être dans votre classe en ce moment
cela ne s'est jamais produit